say what you will about this movie that
is one adorable little cyborg they find
in the middle of nowhere earth to echo
to earth to echo is a found footage
movie with these kids and they go and
they find this little alien the name of
echo now they've got a help et phone
home they gotta go on a scavenger hunt
find these parts of course these
government guys are like excuse me were
you in the desert last night they're
really shady say you know they're not on
the level pretty much what you'd expect
with a bunch of kids trying to help it
alien get the F out of Dodge the kids in
this movie are pretty functional for the
most part a couple of them actually
you're pretty good whatever take you
there his name is munch for some odd
reason I was like I can tell that you're
acting on a camera I don't want to be
right the kids acting ability too much I
understand he's young I don't want to
straight-up say he sucks and have him
lose his mind and burn all the Star Wars
toys and end up looking like Ben Seaver
from growing pains like that one Diggs
it's not good I'm just saying of all the
kids I was like you got a few years to
go now that we were supposed to form
this emotional bond with this err like
one of the kids is like oh he's like I'm
bonding with EKKO you're like all right
yeah I think you look at the movie
you're like wait a minute I'm not bonded
with him either yeah he's cute sure this
is a mean anything I mean if the chips
are down I'll be like all right let go
either you're going home or you're
getting dissected something's gonna
happen
I'm gonna go the movies ending like
imagine if they found Pikachu in a bag
somewhere but he had no development with
any of the characters whatsoever and you
you'd be like oh yeah he's undeniably
cute I just don't care the biggest
problem I had with this movie is what a
lot of these movies that try to emulate
The Goonies and et and they try the like
talking back to the old days of those
kid adventure movies that we grew up on
the like oh I want to make one for this
generation what they do wrong is what
they did wrong in this movie I'm going
to tell you what it is so if you're a
filmmaker out there you can take Knossos
the fact is these kids in this movie
don't act like kids these kids are in
what junior high these are junior high
students with no parents around
whatsoever they would say [ __ ] that
would make their parents [ __ ] all three
of khaleesies dragon eggs if they heard
them I guess I'm saying have kids curse
have them be human because they would do
that like an et the older brother sees
eating he's like what's all this [ __ ]
Elliott calls his brother penis breath
in the goonies mouth was crude they
broke the dick off the statue you know
just like normal funny human [ __ ]
directors these days you try to
recapture that feeling in their movies
don't do it because they don't want to
push
envelope but like nah but we need to
make it PG by that they're just
compromising the entire experience
that's what I liked about super 8 super
right the kids cussed and they were
crude and I was like that's awesome
it truly did hearken back to that time
this movies are rated PG movie you can
completely tell the kids just talk but
none of them said one of them says balls
once and it actually was cool I was like
oh they're gonna do no no they don't I
feel like this movie was written by
someone who doesn't actually have kids
and if they have kids they have this
idealistic version of their kids in
their heads and that's what they put on
paper at that point they should just
remember what they were like as kids and
they should write that so it's earth to
echo that movie of this generation is it
the next Goonies the next et then extend
by me the next showgirls what no not
really it's not it's a scavenger hunt
each movie with a found footage element
to it and that it has the same kind of
build-up that any other found footage
movie has in which case you're like
alright that's kind of boring at this
point it's 2014 I've seen it all and all
builds is the same way it's just a bunch
of friends hanging out and that's what
they're doing in this movie and that's
what they've done in every found footage
movie ever I was really torn on this I
was like is it positive is it not
because the fact is this if I felt this
movie was made for young kids we're
talking six-year-olds if you're like
alright yeah sure did its job and maybe
they'll have a good time with it I don't
think that's the case this movie was
clearly made for the junior high middle
school demographic and they're gonna be
bored out of their minds they're gonna
buy tickets to earth to echo sure but
that's so they can sneak in to deliver
us from evil the way I see it if I had a
six-year-old kid he was like dad I want
to go see Earth Day I would be like
alright let's go watch How to Train Your
Dragon 2 for the 7th time cuz that's
what we're doing because it's still in
theaters so we're not watching earth to
echo I guess so I can't push you guys
I'm just saying earth to echo would
probably be a pretty good time if you're
drunk
ya know it's a party oh we're gonna echo
where's the good [ __ ] behind closed
doors I'm telling your kids they're
actually human beings movie should
probably make them that way so what is
your nostalgic childhood movie that you
watch now in your life yep maybe it's
nostalgia that makes you gret maybe the
movie itself is great fact is I think
it's great because that's my childhood
adventure movie whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more